ALLEN ARCHULETA ATKINS BATES
BAKER FOR DRESS BRADFORD
CABALLERO. THREE SALLY DODD
DORADO EGGMAN LASER GONZALEZ
WROTE. BURKE WESO HER TADO JONES
KAMLAGER LAYERED LEYVA LIMÓN
MCGUIRE MELENDEZ MEN NEWMAN
NIELSEN A CHOI BOGUE HAND
PORTANTINO ROTH. RUBIOINNER
KERN NUMBER WHITE HOUSE SKI
WIENER WELL. THANK YOU MADAM
SECRETARY MEMBERS A QUORUM IS
PRESENT WITH OUR MEMBERS AND OUR
GUESTS BEYOND THE REAL AND IN
THE GALLERY PLEASE RISE WILL BE
LED IN PRAYER THIS MORNING BY
SENATOR LAYERED AFTER WHICH
PLEASE REMAIN STANDING AND WILL
BE LED IN THE PLEDGE OF
ALLEGIANCE TO THE FLAG BY
SENATOR GROW. ENATOR LAYERED.
MEMBERS ARE IN THIS MONTH OF-
WOMEN'S HISTORY MONTH WE
RECOGNIZE AND PRAY FOR EVERYONE
THAT HAS BEEN A TREND SETTER A
TRAILBLAZER AND BROUGHT US TO
THIS MOMENT IN THEIR NAME I ASK
THAT WE ALL JOIN IN THIS PRAYER.
A MAN. THANK YOU MEMBERS PLEASE
PUT YOUR HAND OVER YOUR HEART
HEN SALUTE I PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE.
MEMBERS WITHOUT OBJECTION WE
WILL MOVE TO ASSEMBLY THIRD
READING FILE ITEM TWENTY THREE
AB SEVEN SIXTY NINE THIRTY HUESO
ARE YOU PREPARED. HE IS MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE READ ASSEMBLY
BILL SEVEN SIXTY NINE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER GRAYSON AN ACT
RELATING TO BUSINESS AND
ACQUIRING THE URGENCY THERE UP
SIGNIFICANTLY. SENATOR HUESO.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
SENATORS I'M PLEASED TO PRESENT
TO YOU ASSEMBLY BILL SEVEN SIXTY
NINE WHICH AUTHORIZES UNTIL JUNE
THIRTIETH. TWENTY TWENTY TO. A
CORPORATION TO CONDUCT ITS
ANNUAL SHAREHOLDERS MEETING
REMOTELY AS MANY OF YOU KNOW
THIS PANDEMIC- WAS VERY HARD ON
OUR ENTIRE COMMUNITY- AND WELL
GENERALLY GENERALLY CALIFORNIA
LAW REQUIRES THAT CALIFORNIA
CORPORATIONS MUST. HAVE SOME
TYPE OF IN PERSON- COMPONENT TO
THEIR ANNUAL MEETINGS- THE START
OF THE PANDEMIC- CREATED SOME
FLEXIBILITY. IN ALLOWING
CORPORATIONS TO CONDUCT THEIR
BUSINESSES REMOTELY OR MOTHER
MEDIANS. THIS HAS BEEN A SUCCESS
SO FAR ESPECIALLY IN HELPING
MANAGE THE EFFECTS OF THE
PANDEMIC SO- UNDER THIS BILL-
THAT EXECUTIVE ORDER BYE BYE OF
- THE LEGISLATURE AND KNOWS AN
EXECUTIVE ORDER BY GOVERNOR
NEWSOM- THAT ALLOWED
CORPORATIONS TO MEET REMOTELY IS
SET TO EXPIRE MARCH THIRTY
FIRST. AND FOR SOME OF THESE
CORPORATIONS THAT ARE STILL
CONDUCTING BUSINESSES REMOTELY
THEY'RE JUST SIMPLY ASKING FOR
AN EXTENSION TILL JUNE THOSE A
FEW MORE MONTHS AND AS THINGS
CONTINUE TO RECOVER- WE MUST
ALLOW THEM SUFFICIENT
FLEXIBILITY SO. THIS BILL WILL
HELP TO PROTECT PUBLIC HEALTH
AND HELP ENSURE THAT THESE
MEETINGS COULD BE STILL
CONDUCTED THESE COMPANIES STILL
RUN- THIS IS A VERY REASONABLE
BILL I HOPE WE CAN COUNT ON
EVERYBODY SUPPORT TODAY. YOU
CENTER HUESO MEMBERS ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. SEEING AND
HEARING NONE BEEN SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN
ARCHULETA. OR AYE ATKINS AYE
BATES AYE BECKER AYE FORGES AYE
BRADFORD AYE CABALLERO AYE FOR
TESTING AYE DALY. I DODD.
THEY'RE AWESOME I EGGMAN AYE
GLAZER I GONZALEZ I GROWTH. I
HERTZBERG. I WESTERN OR ARE YOU
HER TADO. JONES I KAMLAGER I
LAYERED I LEYVA. I LIMÓN AYE
MCGUIRE AYE MELENDEZ AYE MIN AYE
NEWMAN AYE NIELSEN. OCTOBER I
PAN I PORTANTINO. I ROTH AYE
RUBIO. I SKINNER I STERN. NUMBER
I LIKE HOW SKI AYE WIENER AYE
WILK HI PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. ALLEN DODD. HER TADO I
NIELSEN STERN. FIVE THIRTY SIX
NO ZERO ON THE URGENCY HIGHS
THIRTY SIX NO ZERO THE MEASURE
PASSES. MESSAGES FROM THE
GOVERNOR WILL BE DEEMED READ NOT
A PRESIDENT IF I CAN JUST
PLEASE- MAKE A FORMAL REQUEST
HERE- YES- MERRY AMERISPEC FULLY
REQUESTED THE BILL. BE
TRANSMITTED IMMEDIATELY TO THE
ASSEMBLY WE WILL HANDLE THAT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH SENATOR
HUESO. MEMBERS MESSAGES FROM THE
GOVERNOR WILL BE DEEMED READ
MESSAGES FROM THE ASSEMBLY WILL
BE DEEMED READ REPORTS OF
COMMITTEES WILL BE DEEMED READ
AND AMENDMENTS ADOPTED MOTIONS
RESOLUTIONS AND NOTICES. SEEING
NONE MOVE WE'RE MOVING NOW TO
CONSIDERATION OF THE DAILY FILE
SECOND READING FILE MA'AM
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. SENATE
BILL NINE EIGHTEEN ELEVEN OH SIX
AND SENATE BILL TEN EIGHTY. THE
SECOND READING FILE WILL BE
DEEMED READ WE ARE NOW MOVING TO
SENATE THIRD READING WE'RE
STARTING WITH FILE ITEM NUMBER
FOUR SENATOR RUBIO MA'AM
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. SENATE
RESOLUTION SIXTY ONE BY SENATOR
RUBIO RELATIVE TO UNACCOMPANIED
WOMEN EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS
AWARENESS MONTH. THE RUBIO THANK
YOU MADAM PRESIDENT LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN OF THE SENATE TODAY I
RISE TO PRESENT S. R. SIXTY ONE.
IT RESOLUTION DECLARING THE
MONTH OF MARCH TWENTY TWENTY TWO
AS UNACCOMPANIED WOMEN
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS
AWARENESS MONTH AND THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. NATIONALLY
UNACCOMPANIED WOMEN MAKE UP
NEARLY ONE IN THREE OF ALL ADULT
INDIVIDUALS EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS BUT DESPITE MAKING
A SIGNIFICANT PORTION OF THE
HOMELESS POPULATION THEIR UNIQUE
NEEDS HAVE LARGELY FALLEN
THROUGH THE CRACKS. IN ADDITION
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE IS ONE OF THE
LEADING CAUSES OF HOMELESSNESS
FOR WOMEN. OFTENTIMES WHEN A
WOMAN IS ABLE TO LEAVE THE
ABUSER HE LEAVES WITH NOTHING
BUT THE CLOTHING ON HER BACK.
WITH LITTLE RESOURCES AND NO
SHELTER THESE WOMEN FACE A
DIFFICULT AND DANGEROUS
ENVIRONMENT ON THE STREETS. WE
AS A LEGISLATURE MUST DO MORE TO
ENSURE THAT CALIFORNIA'S
HOMELESS POPPED UP POPULATION.
IS TAKING CARE OF AND THAT WE
RESPOND TO THOSE NEEDS THAT IS
WHY I HAVE INTRODUCED SB NINE
ONE FOUR THIS YEAR THE HELP ACT
WHICH STANDS FOR HOMELESS EQUITY
FOR LEFT BEHIND POPULATIONS. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE IN THIS IMPORTANT
RESOLUTION LET'S MAKE SURE THAT
WE REMEMBER THESE WOMEN AS WE
WORK TOWARDS ENDING
HOMELESSNESS. THANK YOU AND I
ASK FOR YOUR IPHONE. THANK YOU
CENTER RUBIO MEMBERS ANY
QUESTIONS COMMENTS CONCERNS.
SEEING AND HEARING NONE MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN AYE ARCHULETA AYE ATKINS
AYE BATES. I BAKER I FOR JUST.
BRADFORD I HAVE A ADAM I
PRETENDING AYE DALY. I DODD I
TORONTO I EGGMAN. GLAZER I
GONZALEZ I GROW. I REQUEST SO. I
HER TADO I JONES FIVE KAMLAGER I
LAYERED I LEYVA AYE THE MON I
MCGUIRE. I MELENDEZ FIVE MILLION
I NEWMAN AYE NIELSEN. I A
TROUBLE I CAN. HI PORTANTINO AYE
ROTH AYE RUBIO. SKINNER I STERN
NUMBER HI I QUITE CASKEY I
WIENER AYE WILK. HI PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS. PORGES I
EGGMAN I GROWTH. I RUBIO I- I
THIRTY NINE ZERO THE RESOLUTION
IS ADOPTED MEMBERS WE ARE MOVING
ON THE FILE ITEM NUMBER EIGHT
SAID UNDER HER TADO MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE READ SENATE
CONCURRENT RESOLUTION SEVENTY
SIX BY SENATOR TADO RELATIVE TO
SUDDEN UNEXPLAINED DEATH IN
CHILDHOOD AWARENESS MONTH.
SENATOR HER TADO. THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT MEMBERS I'M HERE
TO PRESENT S. YOUR SEVENTY SIX
AS YOUR SEVENTY SIX PROCLAIMS
THE MONTH OF MARCH. TWO THOUSAND
AND TWENTY TO A SUDDEN
UNEXPLAINED DEATH IN CHILDHOOD
AWARENESS MONTH. SUDDEN
KNOWN AS SUDC IS A CATEGORY OF
DEATH IN CHILDREN WHERE THE
CAUSE OF DEATH REMAINS
UNEXPLAINED AFTER A THOROUGH
INVESTIGATION AN AUTOPSY. IT IS
FREQUENTLY SEEN AS A HEALTHY
CHILD GOING TO SLEEP AND NOT
WAKING UP. FOR ANY REAL REASON
S. U. D. C. AS A BROADER
CATEGORY IS FILLED WITH UNKNOWNS
INCLUDING ITS CALLS HOW TO
PROTECT IT AND HOW TO PREVENT
IT. IN THE UNITED STATES ABOUT
FOUR HUNDRED CHILDREN ARE LOST
TO SUDC EVERY YEAR IT IS THE
FIFTH LEADING CATEGORY OF DEATH
FOR CHILDREN BETWEEN THE AGES OF
ONE AND FOUR. IT IS VITAL THAT
WE PROMOTE AWARENESS OF SUDC AND
PROVIDE. A SUPPORT TO THOSE
AFFECTED BY IT I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU
SENATOR HER TADO MEMBERS IT. ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE SEEING AND
HEARING NONE IT. GIVE ME A
MEMBERS THIS IS ELIGIBLE FOR
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL IS THERE ANY
OBJECTION TO USING A UNANIMOUS
ROLL CALL THING IN HER NINE FIVE
THIRTY NINE NO ZERO THE
RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED MEMBERS WE
ARE MOVING ON TO. FILE ITEM
NINETEEN BUT SENATOR BORCHERS
SENATOR PORCHES ARE YOU READY TO
PRESENT. MAN SECRETARY PLEASE
READ. SENATE RESOLUTION SEVENTY
SIX FIVE SENATOR WATCHES
RELATIVE TO GREEK INDEPENDENCE
DAY. CENTER BORDERS THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT. BETTER
PRESIDENT AND MEMBERS I RISE
TODAY TO ASK YOU FOR YOUR
SUPPORT FOR SENATE RESOLUTION
SEVENTY SIX COMMEMORATING GREEK
INDEPENDENCE DAY. GREEK
INDEPENDENCE DAY IS A NATIONAL
HOLIDAY CELEBRATED ANNUALLY ON
MARCH TWENTY FIFTH COMMEMORATING
THE START OF THE WAR OF GREEK
INDEPENDENCE IN EIGHTEEN TWENTY
ONE. FOR ALMOST FOUR HUNDRED
YEARS GREECE WAS UNDER THE REIGN
OF THE OTTOMAN EMPIRE ORTHODOX
GREEKS WERE GRANTED FEW RIGHTS
IN OFTEN CONSIDERED INFERIOR
SUBJECTS UNDER OTTOMAN RULE. THE
GREEK REVOLT BEGAN ON MARCH
TWENTY FIFTH EIGHTEEN TWENTY ONE
WHEN BISHOP YOUR MANOS APOTHEKEN
RAISE THE FLAG OF REVOLUTION
OVER THE MONASTERY OF I ALLOW
THAT ARE. IN THE IN THE
PELOPONNESE. JUST AS THE
REVOLUTION APPEARED TO BE ON THE
VERGE OF FAILURE GREAT BRITAIN
FRANCE AND RUSSIA INTERVENED IN
THE CONFLICT. THE GREEK STRUGGLE
HAD ELICITED STRONG SYMPATHY IN
EUROPE THE REVOLUTION ENDED IN
EIGHTEEN TWENTY NINE WITH THE
TREATY OF ETERNAL ESTABLISHING
AN INDEPENDENT GREEKS STATE.
LAST YEAR IN HONOR OF THIS TWO
HUNDREDTH ANNIVERSARY OF GREEK
INDEPENDENCE THERE WERE
CELEBRATIONS HELD AROUND THE
WORLD. THIS YEAR AS WE LOOK TO
COMMEMORATE THE OCCASION. WE
MUST NOT LOSE SIGHT OF THE
INDEPENDENCE THE STATE
KNOWLEDGES. AS WAR HAS ERUPTED
IN UKRAINE. AND THERE FOR FIGHT
FOR FREEDOM FROM AUTOCRACY IN
DICTATORSHIPS. MEMBERS WE ARE
EXPERIENCING A PERIOD OF
GEOPOLITICAL GAMESMANSHIP WITH
ABSOLUTE HISTORICAL REVISIONISM
AS RUSSIA TRIES TO ASSERT
CONTROL. OVER THE DOMAIN OF ITS
FORMER SOVIET SATELLITES.
OBVIOUSLY RESULTING IN
UNNECESSARY BLOODSHED AND TERROR
FOR THE PEOPLE OF UKRAINE. IN AN
ALARMING PARALLEL. THE REPUBLIC
OF TURKEY HAS PUBLICLY DECLARED
LOOSELY ENTREATY WILL EXPIRE
NEXT YEAR. AND THIS WAS THE
TREATY IN NINETEEN TWENTY THREE
DIMARCO LINES BETWEEN GREECE AND
TURKEY. MORE SPECIFICALLY THERE
IS ACTIVE TALK AND CONCERN THAT
TURKEY HAS DESIGNS TO PHYSICALLY
OCCUPIED THE EASTERN A JIAN
ISLANDS. ONE OF THESE ISLANDS IS
THE VERY ISLAND WHERE MY FAMILY
IS FROM IN SOME OF YOU IN HERE
ACTUALLY HAVE CONNECTIONS TO
OTHER ISLANDS IN THAT SAME
VICINITY. BUT MEMBERS IS THAT
THIS IS ALL VERY IMPORTANT STILL
IRRELEVANT AS GREEK INDEPENDENCE
DAY DOESN'T JUST RECOGNIZE THE
STORK WAR WITH THE OTTOMAN
EMPIRE OVER TWO HUNDRED YEARS
AGO BUT ALSO THE ONGOING THREAT
FROM PRESIDENT ORDER ONE FROM
THE REPUBLIC OF TURKEY TODAY. AS
GREECE IN THE UNITED STAES
CONTINUE TO STAND TOGETHER AS
FRIENDS AND ALLIES. LET US
RECOGNIZE OUR SHARED LOVE FOR
FREEDOM LIBERTY AND INDIVIDUAL
RIGHTS. LET THIS RESOLUTION BE A
GESTURE TO RECOGNIZE THE
SIGNIFICANT CONTRIBUTIONS GREECE
HAS GIVEN TO OUR GOLDEN STATE.
AND FINALLY LETTER SHORE SUPPORT
FOR GREECE STAYING INDEPENDENT
FROM EXTERNAL THREATS. MEMBERS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT OF S. R. SEVENTY SIX
COMMEMORATING TWO HUNDRED THE
FIRST ANNIVERSARY OF GREEK
INDEPENDENCE THANK YOU SENATOR
BOARD JUST MEMBERS ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. SEEING AND
HEARING NINE MEMBERS THIS IS
ELIGIBLE FOR A UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL IS THERE ANY OBJECTION TO
USING A UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL.
THING IN HEARING NINE FIVE
THIRTY NINE NO ZERO THE
RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED MEMBERS WE
ARE NOW MOVING TO THE CONSENT
CALENDAR BEFORE WE VOTE ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR IS THERE
ANYTHING ANYONE WOULD LIKE TO
HAVE REMOVED. SEEING AND HEARING
NONE MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE READ
. SENATE BILLS FOURTEEN NINETY
FOURTEEN NINETY ONE AND SENATE
BILL FOURTEEN NINETY TWO. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALLEN I ARCHULETA AYE
ATKINS AYE BATES. BAKER I
PORCHES AYE BRADFORD. I HAVE
ITEM I PROTECTING AYE DOLLY. I
DODD. I TORONTO I EGGMAN AYE
GLAZER AYE GONZALEZ I GROWTH I
HERTZBERG AYE WESTERN. HI HER
TADO I JONES AIN'T NOBODY I
KAMLAGER I LAYERED. I LEYVA AYE
LIMÓN. I REQUIRE I MELENDEZ I
MEN I NEWMAN AYE NIELSEN. I
UNTIL ABOUT FIVE PAN AYE
PORTANTINO AYE ROTH AYE RUBIO I
SKINNER AYE STERN NUMBER I AM
FIVE FOUR CASKEY. I WIENER. WELL
HI PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. BATES I STERN WIENER HI. I THIRTY NINE KNOWS ZERO THE
CONSENT CALENDAR HAS BEEN
ADOPTED MEMBERS WE'RE GOING TO
MOVE TO COMMITTEE ANNOUNCEMENTS
AND THEN WE'LL MOVE BACK TO
RETURN RETURNING TO MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS WE WILL BE DOING
ADJOURNMENT REYES AND I WILL ASK
EVERYONE TO PLEASE TAKE THEIR
SEATS LET'S GO TO COMMITTEE
ANNOUNCEMENTS FIRST. FURTHERMORE
JUST. THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT-
COMMITTEE WILL BE MEETING IN
ROOM TWENTY TWO HUNDRED IN OUR
NEW HOME- BUT APPARENTLY NOT
IMMEDIATELY AFTER GERMAN BUT AT
TEN O'CLOCK VERY GOOD EGG
COMMITTEE TEN O'CLOCK ROOM
TWENTY TWO HUNDRED SENATOR
WIENER I THANK YOU- COLLEAGUES
ARE THAT THE HOUSING COMMITTEE
WILL BE MEETING IN ROOM TWENTY
ONE HUNDRED THE SWING SPACE
WE'RE GOING TO BE STARTING
PRECISELY AT TEN O'CLOCK NOT
ATTEND A ONE TIME OCCURRENCE OF
PEOPLE COULD PLEASE. PLEASE BE
THERE A FEW MINUTES BEFORE TEN I
WOULD APPRECIATE IT THANK YOU
HOUSING TWENTY ONE HUNDRED AT
TEN TEN TEN O'CLOCK TO ELEVEN
O'CLOCK TEN O'CLOCK NO YOU SAID
TEN YOU'RE GOOD YOU'RE GOOD
THANK YOU MEMBERS ALRIGHT WE ARE
RETURNING TO MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS FOR OUR JOURNEY
MEMORIES IF I CAN ASK ALL
MEMBERS TO PLEASE TAKE THEIR
SEATS. AND STOP IN THE SIDEBAR
CONVERSATIONS. SO THAT WE CAN
PROPERLY. MEMORIALIZE THOSE THAT
HAVE PASSED. SENATOR ATKINS.
MADAM PRESIDENT THANK YOU SO
MUCH COLLEAGUES I RISE TO
ADJOURN IN MEMORY OF VISIONARY
BIOCHEMIST DR RICHARD LERNER WHO
DIED AT THE AGE OF EIGHTY THREE
THIS PAST DECEMBER DR LERNER WAS
BORN ON AUGUST TWENTY SIX
NINETEEN THIRTY EIGHT IN CHICAGO
HE SPENT HIS EARLY YEARS BEFORE
ATTENDING NORTHWESTERN
UNIVERSITY FOR COLLEGE. IN
NINETEEN SIXTY FOUR HE OBTAINED
HIS MD FROM STANFORD MEDICAL
SCHOOL AND THEN BEGAN POST
DOCTORATE TRAINING AT SCRIPPS
CLINIC AND RESEARCH FOUNDATION.
WHERE HE SERVED ON THE FACULTY
FOR THE REST OF HIS LIFE. HE WAS
NAMED CHAIRMAN OF THE DEPARTMENT
OF MANEK MOLECULAR BIOLOGY IN
NINETEEN EIGHTY TWO AND THEN
PROMOTED TO DIRECTOR. OF THE
SCRIPTS CLINIC FIVE YEARS LATER
. UNDER IS TWENTY FOUR YEARS OF
LEADERSHIP THE SCRIPTS CLINIC
NEARLY TRIPLED IN SIZE AND
BECAME AN ELITE CENTER. A
PHARMACEUTICAL AND MEDICAL
RESEARCH. IN FACT BENJAMIN LIST
ONE OF WARMERS FORMER
POSTDOCTORAL RESEARCHERS. AND
ARDEN. ARDEN AT TWO PM AT TWO PM
ONE OF THE INSTITUTE'S CURRENT
SCHOLARS FOR GIVE ME COLLEAGUES
I'M PRETTY SURE A MASSACRE THAT
NAME. BUT IT'S INCREDIBLY
IMPORTANT BECAUSE EACH OF THOSE
GENTLEMAN WON A NOBEL PRIZE THIS
PAST FALL. DR LEARNERS RESEARCH
FOCUSED ON DNA AND THE BODY'S
PRODUCTION OF ANTIBODIES TO
FIGHT INFECTION. WHICH WAS
INSTRUMENTAL IN THE DEVELOPMENT
OF A VAST ARRAY OF DIFFERENT
TREATMENTS AMONG WHICH IS THE
DRUG. MERA THE MERA IS USED TO
TREAT ARTHRITIS CANCER AND
DIABETES AND HAS BEEN USED TO
TREAT COUNTLESS PATIENTS
WORLDWIDE. DR LERNER DESCRIBED
HIMSELF AS A LAB RAT AND HE WAS
DEDICATED TO APPLYING CHEMISTRY
TO FIND NEW WAYS TO HELP FIGHT
ILLNESSES. IN TRUTH HE WAS
REALLY NOTHING SHORT OF A GENIUS
A VISIONARY WHO HELPED ESTABLISH
ONE OF THE FOREMOST CENTERS OF
MEDICAL RESEARCH TODAY. AS WELL
AS PERSONAL RESEARCH THAT
IMPACTED THOUSANDS IF NOT
MILLIONS OF LIVES. HE IS
SURVIVED BY THREE CHILDREN
DANTICAT ERIC AND AARON HIS WIFE
DR NICOLA GREEN LEARNER. FACTOR
LEARN LEAVE BEHIND A LEGACY OF
SCIENTIFIC INNOVATION AND
EXPANDED UNDERSTANDING OF
MEDICINE AND HEALTH. WE WERE
FORTUNATE TO HAVE HIM BE A
RESIDENT OF CALIFORNIA. I ASK
THAT YOU JOIN ME IN A JOURNEY IN
MEMORY OF DR RICHARD LERNER.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT THANK
YOU SENATOR ATKINS PLEASE BRING
HIS NAME FORWARD SO HE MAY BE
PROPERLY MEMORIALIZED FOR THE
CALIFORNIA STATE SENATE. LEADER
CABALLERO. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT. I RISE TODAY TO
REQUEST THAT WE ADJOURN IN THE
MEMORY OF SALINAS POLICE
OFFICER. BUT HEY THE READ ABOUT
OTHER JUNIOR. WAS KILLED IN THE
LINE OF DUTY ON FEBRUARY TWENTY
FIFTH TWENTY TWENTY TWO. ON THAT
DAY OFFICER. INITIATED A TRAFFIC
STOP. WITHOUT ANY WARNING THE
DRIVER EXITED HIS VEHICLE AND
OPENED FIRE ON OFFICER AVAILABLE
WHO IS SEATED IN HIS VEHICLE.
OFFICER I'LL BUY THAT I BY
ANOTHER RETURNED FIRE INJURING
THE DRIVER BUT TRAGICALLY DIED
DURING THE CONFRONTATION.
OFFICER I'LL READ EITHER OR JD
AS HE WAS KNOWN TO HIS FAMILY
AND FRIENDS WAS BORN AND RAISED
IN SAN FRANCISCO CALIFORNIA THE
FOURTH AND YOUNGEST SON OF A MAN
AND MADINAT ABOUT EITHER. AS A
YOUNG MAN MAN OFFICER ALBERT
EITHER EXHIBITED A GREAT
COMMITMENT TO PUBLIC SERVICE AND
LOVE FOR HIS COUNTRY. AFTER
GRADUATING A YEAR EARLY FROM
HIGH SCHOOL DUE TO HIS ACADMIC
ACHIEVEMENTS IN LISTED IN THE
UNITED STATES ARMY. HE GRABBED
THE GRADUATED INFANTRY SCHOOL AT
FORT BENNING GEORGIA IN TWENTY.
TWENTY EIGHT AND SERVED WITH A
HUNDRED ANDONE AIRBORNE
DIVISION IN FORT CAMPBELL
KENTUCKY. WELL WITH THE
SCREAMING EAGLES HE ATTENDED AND
GRADUATED FROM THE SUBWAY LASKY
AIR ASSAULT SCHOOL. IN TWO
THOUSAND ELEVEN HE WITH A BULLET
DEPLOYED TO AFGHANISTAN WITH THE
WITH THE ROCK ASSIGNED TO THE
THIRD BATTALION A HUNDRED AND
EIGHTY SEVENTH INFANTRY
REGIMENT. DURING OPERATION
ENDURING FREEDOM. WHERE HE
SERVED WITH DISTINCTION.
RECEIVING THE ARMY COMMENDATION
MEDAL AND TWO CITATIONS OF THE
ARMY ACHIEVEMENT MEDAL FOR ITS
ACTIONS IN COMBAT. HE SERVED AS
BOTH A TEAM LEADER AND SQUAD
LEADER WHILE IN THE SERVICE
PROMOTING TO THE RANK OF
SERGEANT. AFTER HONORABLY
COMPLETING HIS ARMY ENLISTMENT
HE RETURNED TO CALIFORNIA AND
ENROLLED AT THE MONTEREY
PENINSULA POLICE ACADEMY. IN
JANUARY TWENTY SIXTEEN HE
COMPLETED THE POLICE ACADEMY AND
JOIN THE RANKS OF THE CALL MY
POLICE DEPARTMENT. AND PROUDLY
SERVE THE RESIDENTS FOR FOUR AND
A HALF YEARS. HE WAS RECRUITED
ENJOYING THE SALINAS POLICE
DEPARTMENT IN TWENTY TWENTY AND
COMPLETED THE S. P. B. TRAINING
PROGRAM BEFORE BEING ASSIGNED AS
A PATROL OFFICER. HE LOVED HIS
WORK AS A PATROL OFFICER AND WAS
DESCRIBED AS A MAN OF INTEGRITY
WHO ALWAYS ARRIVED EARLY TO WORK
WITH AN UPBEAT ATTITUDE AND A
SMILE ON HIS FACE. HE WAS AN
ANIMAL LOVER WHO IS KNOWN TO GO
OUT OF HIS WAY TO PROTECT STRAYS
IN INJURED ANIMALS. HE WAS A
SMART ATHLETIC COMPASSIONATE
CARING MAN WHO LOVED NATURE AND
THE OUTDOORS AND HIS HIGH SCHOOL%
SWEETHEART AND FIANCEE VERONICA.
OFFICER ELDORADO EMBED ARNICA
ELDORADO WERE TO BE MARRIED ON
ST ST PATRICK'S DAY THIS YEAR.
WE RECOGNIZE THE HEROISM OF
OFFICER I READ I ALWAYS HE
FOUGHT FOR HIS COMMUNITY UNTIL
HIS LAST BREATH. HIS DEDICATION
AND COMMITMENT TO THE SALINAS
POLICE DEPARTMENT AND TO THE
COMMUNITY WILL NOT BE FORGOTTEN.
OUR THOUGHTS AND PRAYERS ARE
WITH HIS FIANCEE VERONICA
AVAILABLE HIS PARENTS. RENEE AND
A MEDINA LILITH ABOUT EITHER AND
HIS BROTHERS JORGE AND NESTLE.
FOUR FIFTY THEN AND JORGE
NINETEEN ABOUT EITHER. POLICE
CHIEF ROBERT PHILLIP CHEN AND
THE SALINAS POLICE DEPARTMENT
AND THE ENTIRE SALINAS COMMUNITY
WHO IS IN MOURNING. THANK YOU
MEMBERS I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
THAT THE SENATE ADJOURNED IN HIS
MEMORY TODAY. THANK YOU CENTER
CABALLERO PLEASE BRING HIS NAME
FORWARD SO HE MAY BE PROPERLY
MEMORIALIZED FOR THE CALIFORNIA
STATE SENATE. LEADER CHAU BUG.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR. I RISE TO
JOURNEY MEMORY OF LINDA GOMES
EVANS FROM HEMET CALIFORNIA.
LINDA WAS A DEDICATED COMMUNITY
ORGANIZER AND ACTIVIST AND SHE
WAS KNOWN THROUGHOUT THE STATE
AS THE CO FOUNDER OF THE SISTERS
WARRIORS FREEDOM COALITION.
PASSION OR HER LIFE'S WORK
AROSE FROM HER OWN EXPERIENCE IN
HER YOUTH HE SPENT MANY OF HER
EARLY YEARS IN JAIL AND ENTERED
A GANG AT THE AGE OF. ELEVEN
AFTER THIS EXPERIENCE HE
REFOCUSED ITS PROTECTORATE FOR
LIFE AND DECIDED TO EMPOWER
OTHERS WHO FOUND THEMSELVES IN A
SIMILAR PATH. HE WOULD OFTEN
DRIVE TO GREET PEOPLE AS THEY
WERE RELEASED FROM PRISON
BECAUSE THE SHE BELIEVES THAT
EVERYONE. DESERVE TO BE WELCOMED
INTO THE COMMUNITY WHEN COMING
HOME. HE WAS ALSO A CHAMPION FOR
CIVIC ENGAGEMENT AND TRAIN
HUNDREDS OF PEOPLE EVERY YEAR TO
ENGAGE IN VOTER REGISTRATION
EDUCATION AND LOCAL ELECTION
CAMPAIGNS. LINDA WAS A BEAUTIFUL
EXAMPLE OF WHAT IT MEANS TO AN
AGENT OF CHANGE HE WAS A TRUE IS
FOR INSPIRATION WHO LEFT US MUCH
TOO SOON LINDA WILL BE DEEPLY
MISSED BUT SHE WILL NEVER BE
FORGOTTEN. THANK YOU SENATOR
CHAU BOTH PLEASE BRING HER NAME
FORWARD SO THAT SHE MAY BE
PROPERLY MEMORIALIZED BY THE
CALIFORNIA STATE SENATE. IF
THERE IS NO FURTHER BUSINESS
CENTER ATKINS THE DESK IS CLEAR
. MADAM PRESIDENT THANK US WE
ARE CLOSE OUT TODAY TO YOU AND
TO MY COLLEAGUES I WOULD LIKE TO
EXPRESS MY SINCERE APPRECIATION
FOR THE INCREDIBLE FRAMED
PHOTOGRAPH THAT YOU GAVE TO ME
THIS WEEK. IN HONOR OF THE
FOURTH ANNIVERSARY OF YOUR-
ALLOWING ME TO SERVE AS
PRESIDENT PRO TEM IT WAS AN
INCREDIBLE GESTURE I APPRECIATE
EACH AND EVERYONE OF YOU I LOVE
SERVING WITH YOU. AND I AM
GRATEFUL AND WITH THAT- MAN PRO
TEM- MADAM PRESIDENT HI MONDAY
MARCH TWENTY EIGHTH TWENTY
TWENTY TWO WILL BE OUR NEXT
SESSION AT TWO PM. THANK YOU
THANK YOU MADAM PRO TEM MEMBERS
THE SENATE WILL BE IN RECESS
UNTIL THREE THIRTY AT WHICH TIME
THE ADJOURNMENT MOTION WILL BE
MADE WE WILL RECONVENE MONDAY AT
TWO PM HAVE A GREAT REST TODAY
MEMBERS.